- [Instructor] When you
hear of ancient Rome,
or the Roman Empire,
or the Roman republic,
immediately images of the
Roman legions come to mind.
To the conquering armies conquering
much of the Mediterranean.
You might have images of the Roman Senate.
Names like Julius Caesar and
Augustus might come to mind.
You might think of some of
the famous architectures.
Some of which you can still
see if you were to visit Rome,
and these are all real images of Rome,
or they're appropriately
associated with it,
and we'll talk about most of
these things in some depth,
but Rome did not start out that way,
and the purpose of this
video is to give us
a over arching arc of the history of Rome
to be able to place it within history.
Both in terms of time and geography.
So just to make sure we
can read what I did here
ahead of time, up here is I
have a high level timeline
and then down here I have
a timeline that zooms in
a little bit, goes into
a few more details,
and you can see this timeline on top,
it's going from the eighth century BCE
all the way to the fifth century CE,
so it's covering over
1,000 years of history,
and I need it to cover
over 1,000 years of history
because the Roman Empire,
we can even say just
the western Roman Empire
covers that much,
and that doesn't even
cover the entire legacy
of the Roman Empire
because when we get into
the fourth century CE,
you have a split where
you have the eastern
and the western Roman Empire
and the eastern, often known
as the Byzantine Empire,
that goes on until 1453 CE.
So another 1,000 years
until they are conquered
by the Ottomans.
So the legacy of the Roman Empire,
even formally as an
empire, is significant,
and then it continues on.
Much of western civilization,
especially Europe and the Mediterranean
has its foundations in the Roman Empire
and then before that, Greek civilization,
and the Roman Empire is really up there
alongside the Persian Empire
as one of the really great
civilizations or empires,
and when I say great, you should take that
with a grain of salt.
Great I'm saying it was
big, it was powerful,
but not everything they did was great.
They had a lot of slavery,
they were very cruel,
they were sometimes very violent.
So take these terms great
with a grain of salt.
So now that we get this timeline up here
and then down here I'm gonna go, whoops.
Down here I have some maps
that are gonna show how
the Roman Empire grew
and then eventually splits and declines,
but as we go to this top timeline,
we see the founding of Rome
in the eighth century BCE,
and this date 753 is the
date that's often given
to the founding of Rome by Romulus,
one of twin brothers Romulus
and Remus raised by a she-wolf.
They were abandoned and
raised by the she-wolf
as legend would have it,
and then Romulus eventually
kills his brother
and then becomes the first king of Rome.
We don't know how much of this is true.
I suspect a lot of this is very legendary.
Legend would have it that
Rome is named for Romulus,
but some historians today think
well it might have been
the other way around.
We have the city of Rome,
they needed a founding story,
hey let's say this person
Romulus started it,
and we don't know the exact date,
but there seems to be
a reasonable consensus
that around this mid eighth century BCE
you have the founding of the city of Rome,
but it's important to
realize that at that point
the founding of the city
that the kingdom of Rome,
it wasn't a significant power
on the Italian Peninsula
at the time.
Where I have this X marked,
that's where Rome is,
and what you see in
green, this is actually
the Etruscan civilization,
and for most of this period
of the Roman kingdom.
So this period right over here,
it's actually the Etruscans
that are dominant power
and for significant fractions of this
they were dominant over the Roman kingdom.
Over the city of Rome,
but as we get to 509 BCE,
this is when the Roman
Republic is established
and in this blue green
color, this is the kingdom.
The gold color, this yellow
color is the republic
and then the red color is when
the empire gets established
by Julius Caesar and his
adopted son Augustus,
and as we get into this,
I guess you could say
this republic period of,
or into the Roman Republic.
This is when it starts
to really exert itself
as more of a dominant
influence in the region,
and it continues to be a
dominant influence in the region
for several hundred years,
and then as we get into the
first several hundred years
in the common era.
So after the time of Jesus.
As we get into the 200s, the 300s,
this is when we start
to see a real decline
of the Roman Empire and
the western empire at least
gets sacked multiple times
in the fifth century,
and the year 476 is what's typically given
for the end of the Roman Empire,
but even that's not exactly
the end of the Roman Empire,
because in the fourth century
you have the Roman Empire splitting into
this eastern and western empires,
and the eastern later gets
known as the Byzantine Empire.
That goes on for another 1,000 years
until it's, as I
mentioned, I think earlier,
taken over by the Ottomans,
but to get more appreciation for
how the Roman Empire grew
and then eventually starts to shrink,
I have some maps over here.
So this first map, this
is roughly from the
third century BCE and third century BCE
you might remember Rome is
a republic at this time,
but it's not the dominant
power in the Mediterranean.
Just to give ourselves some bearings,
you might remember that in
the later fourth century BCE
that's when Alexander conquers much of,
or most of Greece, Macedonia,
the Persian Empire.
Which included at the time Egypt,
and as we get into the third century BCE,
you still have the fragments
of Alexanders empire,
but these are still significant
powers in the regions.
You also have the Carthaginian Empire.
Which you see here in blue in North Africa
and southern Spain,
and this period you have a series of wars
between the Romans and the Carthaginians
known as the Punic Wars,
and we'll do videos in
depth on the Punic Wars.
They're called the Punic Wars
because the term Punic, it comes from
what the Romans called the Phoenicians,
and Carthage was actually settled,
founded by ancient Phoenicians.
So you can kinda consider
this the Phoenician War
or the descendants of the Phoenician Wars,
but that's why it's called Punic,
but the Romans eventually
win the multiple rounds
of Punic Wars, take over their territory,
and eventually destroy Carthage.
Carthage is destroyed in 146 BCE,
and we'll talk about that in more detail.
Now as we go into the first century BCE,
this is when Rome goes form
being a republic to an empire,
and it happens when the
general, Julius Caesar,
he's able to conquer Gaul
for the Roman Republic.
So Gaul is modern day France
and some other surrounding regions,
and he is so powerful that
when he comes back to Rome,
a civil war ensues and
Julius Caesar is able to
essentially win the civil war,
declare himself a dictator,
and then his adopted son
Augustus, right over here,
is in 27 BCE declared Emperor,
and that's the beginning
of the Roman Empire,
and we keep going, and I
think I've already mentioned
it once in this video,
but eventually we get a split
in the fourth century CE
where we have eastern and western halves
of the Roman Empire.
The western side centered at Rome,
the eastern side centered at
what was originally Byzantium,
renamed Constantinople,
and today Istanbul,
and as we get into the fifth century,
that's when the western empire
especially starts to
really go into decline
and is eventually sacked in 476,
but the eastern empire keeps on going.